an American family is breathing after a
woman was killed by sharks in the
Bahamas 21 year old Jordan Lindsay was
visiting the islands from California CTM
national correspondent that's Jericka
Duncan shows us how a family vacation
turned into a horrible tragedy police in
the Bahamas say Jordan Lindsey was
attacked by three sharks while
snorkeling off Rose Island Wednesday
afternoon Lindsey's family reportedly
saw the Sharks approaching her and tried
to yell out a warning but she didn't
hear them in time this photo taken by a
woman who was in the water earlier
apparently shows one tiger shark
responsible for the attack
officials say the sharks bit Lindsay's
legs buttocks and severed her right arm
she was pronounced dead at the hospital
unprovoked shark attacks worldwide are
rare and deaths even more so in a
10-year period ending in 2016 the
Bahamas saw just four shark attacks only
one was deadly Lindsey's family
describes her as a beautiful gentle soul
she was a student at Loyola Marymount
University in Southern California the
university's president called her a
devoted animal lover and climate change
advocate a neighbor of Lindsay's family
reacted to the news overnight my heart
is pounding I cannot believe it I don't
know I don't know how through with this
Lindsey's family started a GoFundMe page
to raise money for funeral and travel
expenses the Bahamas ministry of
agriculture and Marine Resources has
issued precautionary advisories to the
public just a sad story on just such a
horrible way to die and it just picked
it it just conjures up such a graphic
picture and this is so rare they say in
the Bahamas shark attack is rare a shark
attack by three sharks is extraordinary
right it was this one that they say
actually killed her but it's a risk that
you take people think about it it rarely
happens but again you know a story like
this puts it out in the limelight at the
forefront again we mentioned the
GoFundMe page there they want
25-thousand help get the body back to
the US they're about a quarter of the
way there
you know Rica thank you very much